Einen großen Aufwand betreibe ich ja eh schon für, ich tue meinem Körper was Gutes. Ich tue mir schwer, mit deiner Erzählung mich anzupfen. Ich tue mir schwer, und das Jan Gustavsson auch immer. Und jetzt ist mir neulich jemand begegnet, der genauso war. Seit wann sagen alle, ich tue mir schwer. Das ist so eine Modeerscheinende, Bayblade-Shit. Das nächste große Ding nach Bayblade. Warum, hast du was gegen den Ausdruck? Soziales Beyblade ist das für mich. Du hast was gegen den Ausdruck. Wir lassen unsere Wörter gegeneinander kämpfen in so einer Arena zwischen uns. Was ist denn falsch an, ich tue mich schwer. Und ich glaube, da gibt es nicht mal irgendwie was dazwischen, das ist einfach falsch. Und das muss man erst mal finden, liebe Leute, in der deutschen Sprache noch was zu finden, was offensichtlich falsch ist. Man kann ja alles sagen. Ja, nee, nee, aber ich bin da für den Sprachwandel. Wir hatten ja auch die Diskussion bei Ohne dich bin ich allein, wo ich auch gesagt hätte, ohne dir bin ich allein. Ja, es kamen viele Fragen, wie lange wir an dem Musical gearbeitet haben. 90 Prozent lief in diese Frage. Wir haben seit ungelogen, seit März, April daran geschrieben.
Und auf jeden Fall, seit April schreiben wir daran.
Ohne dir bin ich allein.
Aber die meiste Zeit haben wir an der Zeile gebracht.
Und ich habe gesagt, nein, ohne dich bin ich allein.
Wenn du es so sagst, klingt es falsch.
Aber intuitiv habe ich mehrmals auch, sorry für die ganze Frage.
Auch gesungen, das war auch falsch gesungen. aber du hast recht, wenn man sich Gedanken darüber macht.
Wenn man sich einen Gedanken darüber macht.
Was war jetzt der Urspringssatz?
Ich tue mir schwer.
Ich tue mich schwer.
Ich tue mir.
Aber ich tue mir was Gutes.
Ich tue mir einen Gefallen. Ja.
Warum ich tue mir...
Das ist ein anderer Satz. Ja, aber warum?
Du bist doch Logiker. Erklär das doch mal
mit logischen
Definitionen.
Ich bin immer noch erst mal Captain, okay?
Ich hole mir ein Stück Kuchen.
Ich bin mittlerweile Captain...
Captain Lock.
Captain Lock. CPT Lock. Lock Tietze, Professor Captain Log Stephan Tietze. Ich freue mich. Ich tue mir etwas Gutes. Ja, du bist da. Ich tue mir schwer. Nee, ich finde das nicht falsch. Aber was, gut, vielleicht, ja, jetzt wenige Grammatiker kommen jetzt auch wieder um die Ecke. Jetzt kommen sie aus ihren Löchern. Jetzt kommen sie aus ihren Löchern. Die Grammatiker, die Logiker. Oh nein, die Grammatiker kommen! Oh nein! Das sind die Stimmsten. Er, sie, es. Genitiv, Daktus, Daktulus. Es muss mit. Er, sie, es, das Esmus mit.
Er, sie, es, das Esmus mit. Also vielleicht kann uns das jemand erklären, warum es so ist und nicht so und warum Stefan recht hat und warum ich falsch liege und der Schachgrossmeister und ich nicht richtig liegen bei dieser Frage und Stefan Rudolfus Tietze da richtig liegen. Weil Schafspieler ja auch alle so unglaublich intelligent sind und alle super gut sprechen können, weil sie fünf Figuren auseinanderhalten können und die von A bis H-H schicken können. Komisch, als du damals das Schachtöne gewonnen hast, hast du das Spiel noch in viel höheren Tönen gelobt als jetzt. Ich finde es auch immer noch toll. Du bist so leicht zu durchschauen, du bist so leicht zu durchschauen, du bist einfach Sand, du rieselst einfach durch alle Dinge, ohne dass was an dir haften bleibt. Wie geht es den Motten? Viele Leute haben geschrieben, dass Motten ernstes Problem sind. Hört mir auf, dieses riesige Mottenbild zu schicken. Aber Leute haben auch geschrieben, wenn du ernsthaft Lebensmittelmotten in deiner Wohnung hast, es scheint ein Begriff zu sein, Lebensmittelmotte. Lebensmittelmotte, ich möchte jetzt Lebensmittel-Mensch genannt werden. Das nennt man sich, das nennt man sich bereits.
Hinter deinem Rücken nennen wir dich, ich und die Community. Habe ich gar nichts dagegen.
Die Medizin, die botanische Community nennt mich bereits.
Der gemeine Lebensmittel-Florin.
Und die haben gesagt, wenn du die wirklich hast, musst du alles offene, alle offene Lebensmittel wegschmeissen und neue kaufen.
Ja, bevor du deinen wahren Ton hier auflegst, haben aber auch viele gesagt, nee, bei der Größe, was mich aber auch negativ stimmt, nee, bei dieser enormen Größe, die du da hast bei dir an Motten, sind es wohl keine Lebensmittelmotten. Heißt, wir können dieses ganze, oh, Lebensmittelmotten sind gefährlich, bla bla bla, können wir hier erstmal kurz ausklammern, auch gut anzusprechen, vielleicht haben wir bei da irgendwie ein Problem gerade mit Lebensmittelboden, das sind bei mir keine Lebensmittelboden. Ich habe sehr related mit einem Pärchen, die haben mir geschrieben, wir haben das auch gerade, wir vermuten, die kommen aus den Bäumen vor unseren Fenstern. Ich liebe diese Vermutungen einfach. Ich habe damit sehr related, weil es klang ähnlich so, die haben die auch ähnlich beschrieben und es beruhigt mich aber auch. Es ist aber auch eine, es ist wie so, ich fühle mich so ein bisschen wie so ein Regent in meiner Wohnung, so ein bisschen so Donald Trump artig, der dann über Amerika reagiert und dann haben die mir so eine sehr einfache Lösung zugeschustert und wir unterschreiben sie einfach hier, dann ist das Problem weg. So fühle ich mich auch gerade mit diesem, die kommen aus den Bäumen vor deinem Fenster. Da denke ich mir, ja, gut, dann ist es nicht mein Problem mehr, ich war nie schuld daran, die sind, they tend to be in the near, sie sind da irgendwo, wenn ich Licht anmache, fliegen die da hin, okay, mache ich einfach die Fenster zu und ich bin das Problem los. Aber was machst du jetzt gegen die Bäume? Das ist ja der viel härtere Feind, bis jetzt warst du verarbeitet mit einer kleinen Motte, die du locker zu Staub zerdrücken konntest, jetzt hast du es mit zwei ausgewachsenen Bäumen zu tun. Und irgendwann sagt dir, die Bäume kommen eigentlich nur von diesem riesigen Berg da. Dein Problem wird immer schwieriger wie das Problem. Dann verschließt du die Augen gerade von deinem Problem. Natürlich verschließt du gerade die Augen, ich bin aber bereit dafür. Und ich denke mir, diese Bäume, die bergen ja nicht unendlich viele Motten und schon gar nicht das ganze Jahr über. Klar, das ist so ein Spawnpunkt. Das lernt man in jedem Videospiel, dass wenn immer wieder neue Gegner kommen, musst du irgendwann den Spawnpunkt zerstören, den Skeletthaufen oder so ein Kram. Gut, es sind Videospiele aber weder Jahreszeiten noch andere äussere Einflüsse. Manche schon, Sims. Sims hat Jahreszeiten? Manche beide davon, Abteil 9 schon, ja. Manchmal schneit es. Ja, manchmal schneit es, dann kann man Schneemann bauen, es. Aber jetzt habe ich in Sims auch nicht mit Spawnpunkten und
grossen Motten zu tun. Nein, das ist zum Beispiel
ein Diablo-Ehrenspielelement, da gibt es allerdings wiederum
keine Jahreszeiten, hast du recht. Und deswegen gibt es
wahrscheinlich da ganzjährig Motten. Naja, ich habe
jedenfalls in meinem schönen, guten Alt Köln, habe ich hier
wahrscheinlich nicht jedes Jahr ganzjährig
Motten, sondern die werden da jetzt halt
so im August noch rausgespawnt
und dann glaube ich nicht mehr. Und ich glaube auch,
dass die Feuchtigkeit, die wir ja gerade hier haben, extrem zuträglich ist, Motten zuträglich ist. Auch eine Vermutung? Leere Vermutungen, wirklich, aber alle Bewohner meines Hauses werden zufrieden gestellt mit diesen einfachen Lösungen, die ich denen präsentiere, wo ich sehr wenig machen muss. Ich bin Regent meiner Wohnung und die Bewohner meiner Wohnung, denen wurde einfach gesagt so, das Problem kommt von außen, die Motten kommen herein, wir, und jetzt habe ich so, wir lassen uns eine Mauer bauen mässig gesagt, lass uns die Fenster immer zumachen, wenn es dunkel ist draussen. In welcher Wohnungskomplex lebst du, dass du diese Art von Gewalt und Macht hast über deine anderen Nachbarn?
Gibt es da so eine Art Ratssitzungen oder so, wo du einfach die Macht an dich reißt, an so einem Pult stehst, vor so einem riesigen Bild von dir, mit einer Trompete? Ich werde angekündigt mit einer Trompete, ja. Und es geht auch darum, die Mitbewohner im Haus einigermaßen auf die gleiche Seite zu holen. Viel Politik auch. Aber auch viel Selbstgespräche, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Jedenfalls, Fenster werden verschlossen, die Motten werden nicht mehr reingelassen. Egal wie das Licht bleibt an, Motten werden nicht mehr reingelassen. Wir haben genug Motten aufgenommen bei uns. Wir haben genug Motten aufgenommen. Jetzt ist die Nachbarn müssen jetzt auch mal Motten aufnehmen. Entschuldigung, ganz kurz, mein Handy ist leer. Kann ich ganz kurz bei Ihnen rein und Ihr Telefon benutzen? Hier kann niemand mehr rein. Nee, Entschuldigung, ich bin sofort wieder. Raus! Ich muss nur ganz kurz. Stefan hat Pfefferspray eingesetzt. Es war sehr effektiv. Es war sehr effektiv. Aber ging das? Ich weiß gar nicht. Pfefferspray? Schlecht. Für die Augen? Salzspray? Sehr gut für die Haare. Aber auch gut für die Augen? Paprikaspray? Nie existent. Kurkuma-Spray? Lecker. Lecker. Aber wenn du Salzspray in die Augen schießt? Was ist Salzspray? Für meine Haare. Damit die griffig werden.
Griffig.
Die Werbeindustrie hat auch ihre Probleme mit Adjektiven, um Haare zu bezeichnen.
Die haben glänzend trockend, aber irgendwas Positives.
Wie sollen denn Haare sein?
Strohig.
Nee, ich meine was Positives, wo wir sagen können, das macht mit ihren Haaren, das macht sie... Formbar.
Na, formbar, das ist auch neutral.
Nee, nee, ich brauche einen Begriff. Ich hab's. Was denn? Griffig. Griffig! Das ist auch immer unangenehm. Nach dem Referat hat die eine Hälfte der Klasse auf den Tisch geklopft, wie als es ein Stammtisch und die andere Hälfte geklatscht. Und dann wechseln die Gruppen wieder, weil sie denken, oh nee, klopfen, klatschen. Bei uns war es immer so, da hat die Klasse geklatscht und die Lehrerin hat geklopft, weil die halt gerade von der Uni kamen und wir dachten, oh ist das fucking cool, Mann. Aber wir haben uns nicht getraut, das auch zu machen, aber es ist cooler. Ich finde es gut, dass es von gewissen Sachen so Next Level Sachen gibt, so der normale Trottel des Kind im Zirkus klatscht, aber in der Uni sagt man, nee, wir klatschen nicht mehr, wir klopfen auf den Tisch. Und das ist einfach Next Level.
Mein Guilty Pleasure ist die furchtbare Show auf Netflix, Too Hot to Handle. Die scheint sehr beliebt zu sein. Ich höre immer wieder Leute, die sagen, oh, ich schaue mir das ja an. Finger weg auf Deutsch. Finger weg, wenn du catchst die Titel, wo es darum geht, die hottesten Menschen der Welt zusammenzupacken auf einer einsamen Insel und dürfen nicht miteinander schlafen, nicht anfassen und so. Wo ich mir auch denke, wenn die mich dahingesteckt hätten und die hätten mir gesagt, du darfst hier eine Woche lang keinen Sex haben. Ja. Und wenn meine Reaktion, ja. Ich glaube, ich wäre erleichtert gewesen. Ich wäre erleichtert, damit der soziale Aspekt. Dank. Will jemand Magic spielen? Ich finde es aber insane, aber ich kenne keinen Menschen, kenne ich wirklich nicht, selbst die, die ordentlich in der Gegend rumvögeln, selbst die können jetzt so eine Woche auf dieser Insel stecken und die würden sagen, ja. Und jetzt dann aber deren Reaktion ist, what, are you serious? Ja, aber das ist doch alles fake. Ja, das ist doch ... Also erstens werden die natürlich gecastet und die werden wahrscheinlich vorgemacht, hey, ihr geht jetzt auf die härteste Sexinsel mit den heißesten Leuten, um dann den Switch zu machen und wahrscheinlich haben die da auch so hinter den Kulissen... Die werden schon geprimed in die Richtung und die haben wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Skripte bekommen. Jedenfalls haben die sich entschieden, noch einen Next Layer an Klatschen hinzuzufügen.
Denn die haben nicht nur, ich habe auch ein bisschen Angst, wahrscheinlich haben andere
Podcaster auch darüber schon gesprochen und so und der Tochterhandel ist gerade in aller Munde,
deswegen wollen wir da jetzt nicht auch noch einen draufsetzen, aber was mir sicher noch
keiner besprochen hat, ist, dass sie nicht so klatschen oder so klatschen, sondern so.
Ach, schnippen? Weil sie sich nicht anfassen dürfen, oder was?
Nee, sich selber darf man anfassen.
Ach, die dürfen nicht klatschen, weil sie sich sonst anfassen wird.
Sie dürfen sich nicht selbst befriedigen, aber sie dürfen die stimulierende Klatschen aussehen.
Aber High Five ist auch verboten.
Nee, die dürfen auch rumschmusen, dürfen die auch.
Aber die dürfen nicht, die dürfen auch klatschen.
Und warum schnippen die dann zum... Das hat sich etabliert. So eine Gruppendynamik hat dazu geführt, dass sie so machen. So eine weide Gruppendynamik. Am Anfang klatschen die noch. Und es wird ja auch nie thematisiert, das wäre auch viel zu boring. Aber das ist, was mir aufgefallen ist, am Ende schnippen die alle nur noch. Das ist ja fantastisch. Am Anfang klatschen die noch. Und von Folge zu Folge machen immer mehr den, bis am Ende alle so Mr. Krabs-mäßig rumschnippen.
Egal wo ihr seid, in welchem Kontext ihr seid, wenn bei euch geklatscht wird, sei es im Büro, nach einem Meeting oder so, versucht mal langfristig zu etablieren, das auf Schnippen umzubauen. Und dann, wenn ich es geschafft habe, wieder zurück zu klatschen. Ich dachte dann kurz, ich habe mich gefühlt wie jemand, der mit einem Roller rumfährt und sich von einer Gruppe Teenager auf die Fresse legt, weil ich dachte, ah okay, die Welt hat mich abgehängt ein bisschen. Die coolen, hotten Leute mit den durchtrainierten, krassen Megabodies, die auf dieser Insel gesteckt werden, die klatschen so. Und ich dachte kurz, Moment, was? Hol mir einen Block, um das aufzuschreiben, dass Menschen jetzt so klatschen. Haben wir ein Update bekommen für Klatschen? Nicht, dass ich vorbei bin. Aber kommt es nicht so aus dieser Poetry Slam, Beatnik, Poetry-Ecke oder so, dass man da so schnippt? Ich habe das schon mal irgendwo gehört. Hot Take, keiner von denen hat das von einem Poetry Slam aufgeschnappt. Okay, gut, wie du meinst. Aber ich weiß nicht, woher das kommt. Aber ich bin ein Riesenfan von Applaus. Egal in welcher Situation, ich versuche immer klatschen zu etablieren. Wenn du in einem Kochkurs bist, immer versuchen, weil immer wenn du in so einer Gruppendynamik bist, reicht es oft, wenn eine Person anfängt zu klatschen. Und immer wenn die Kochlehrerin sagt so, ja, und dann rührt er das rein und am Ende kommt die Glasur drüber und dann ist das Gericht fertig.
Und du mit deiner Schürze so.
Einfach klatschen, einfach losklatschen. Du mit dem Kiss the Chef mit deiner Schürze. Ja. Super, vielen Dank auch dir. Und alle klatschen mit und immer wenn am Ende jeder Stunde jeder sein Gericht präsentiert, einfach nach jedem Mal klatschen. Und es wird sich einfach einbürgern. Ich bin gerne dieser unsympathische Mensch, der, nachdem dann die Köchin zum Beispiel gesagt hat, vielen Dank an euch, ihr habt das toll gemacht, der einzige aus der Gruppe, der dann sagt, nee, vielen Dank auch dir für das Erklären. Weil es so ein bisschen so ein... Nee, und einmal noch Applaus für Rita, für dich, sie hat das richtig super gemacht, ich finde sie hat das richtig super gemacht, ein viel zu großer Applaus, uh, fuck it. Du läufst zu ihr und nimmst ihr Handgelenk und reißt es in die Luft und so nee, Rita, finde ich richtig gut. Du bist das Arschloch und alle aus der Gruppe hassen dich aber, weil es so maximal einschleift. Und sie mag dich sehr. Das ist ja grossartig. Du setzt alle Punkte auf sie, aber soziale Punkte, aber du lässt halt deine Gruppe hinter dir, es muss dir klar werden, dass du die abwirfst, wie so die Echse den Schwanz. Das ist so ein Schlachtfeld einfach so geil. Weil das Ding mit Klatschen ist, es gibt keinen sozialen Mechanismus, der Klatscherwartungen wieder zurücknimmt. Es gibt kein Element, das hier Gleichgewicht schafft. Wenn sich mal etabliert hat, dass man nach jedem Essen klatscht, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, das wieder zurückzunehmen. Noch nie in der Geschichte
der Menschheit hat jemand gesagt, ey Leute, übrigens,
wir müssen nicht unbedingt immer klatschen nach
jedem Arbeitsschritt.
Das ist gar nicht nötig. Gibt es nicht.
Es geht nur nach oben.
Musicaldarstellern sprechen an Broadway, weil bei unserer
Book of Moment... Sollte möglich sein.
Bei unserer Book of Moment-Vorstellung
nämlich haben
nach jedem Song die Leute geklatscht. Jetzt ist meine Frage, eingenommen, alle sind schlecht gelaunt im Publikum oder keine Ahnung, hatten einen schlechten Tag, was auch immer. Durch eine komische Ansammlung an Ereignissen davor ergibt es sich, dass nach dem ersten Song nicht geklatscht wird. Ich glaube, ich würde es jetzt durch die ganze Vorstellung ziehen. Auf jeden Fall. Aber man klatscht hier nicht. Das ist das Ding. Du hast eine enorme Macht in so Entscheidungsverwenden, weil selbst wenn eine Person nach dem ersten Song klatscht, man kann ja nicht alleine lassen. Das wäre unhöflich, dann würde man ja signalisieren, ich fand den Song schlecht, wenn man dann nicht klatschen würde, wenn eine Person klatscht. Du musst mitziehen. Also du hast bei Klatschen in sozialen Situationen alleine die Macht, wirklich Dinge zu setzen, die dann durchgezogen werden. Noch nie hat ein Mensch so viel Macht, um solche Gruppen beherrschen zu können, wie in solchen Applaus-Situationen. Ich war am Wochenende jetzt bei dem Filmfestival Seesüchte, International Student Film Festival in der Uni Babelsberg. Das ist ein Wortspiel, oder? Seesüchte, richtig, völlig richtig. Also nicht Sehen. Seesüchte im Sinne von Sehen. Und ich war da in der Jury. Aber Sehen, das heisst doch auch Sehen. Schau, ich verstehe es nicht. Sehensüchte. Sehensüchte, oder wie? Nee, Seesüchte. Wie ein grosser Te See oder was? S-E-H-Süchte. Ich glaube, es kommt von Sehensüchte, aber es kommt ja von sich etwas hersehnen, sich wohin sehnen. Und das war jetzt auf Sehen bezogen, Sehsüchte. Aber warum heißt das nicht Sehensüchte? Das muss die Veranstalter fragen. Okay. Aber ich bin da auch bei dir. Ich war jedenfalls da, hatte großen Spaß gemacht und habe da dann erst so eine Woche lang abgehangen bei denen. Und da war ich in der Jury für den besten Pitch. Mit der lieben Kollegin Jana Nanzig, fantastische Autorin. Und mit der war ich da auch in der Jury. Und sie hat ein bisschen mich vor die Gleise geworfen, auf die Gleise geworfen, weil sie hat nämlich den Mut gemacht, dass nach jedem Male nach dem Pitch haben wir dann halt noch Fragen stellen dürfen und so ein bisschen was fragen können zu den Pitches als Jury und dann habe ich dann was gefragt und dann kamen die Studenten geantwortet und so und sie kam dann immer nach mir und hat jedes Mal gesagt also erstmal vielen Dank für den tollen Pitch und ihr hattest ja ganz fantastisch gemacht und ich habe ihr danach gesagt das ist yes, das kannst du nicht bringen. Das ist super. Und ich meinte, hä, wieso, ich wollte das doch sagen und ich meinte, ja, aber ich habe es nicht gesagt davor und lässt du mich aussehen wie ein Arschloch. Es ist genau wie irgendwo beim Essen oder so nach jemandem, der weniger Trinken gegeben hat, irgendwie das Doppelte an Trinken zu geben. Du wirfst den einfach vor die Hunde. Da ist gar keine Diskussion. Und noch mal vielen Dank für den tollen Abend und die Einladung. Und einfach alle, die davor waren, das geht nicht. Das gemein, man setzt derste setzt den Maßstab für den Ton. Wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen zu bossy war und angefangen habe, dich wieder zu beleidigen, heißt das ja nicht, dass sie danach dann sagen kann, erst mal vielen Dank für diesen tollen Pitch, diese tolle Serie. Das ist so ein bisschen so ein ... Erst mal Applaus für euch. Also ich fand's toll. Nee, wirklich mal Applaus. Applaudiert euch ruhig selber. Und ich als Lord Voldemort, soll ich dann auch anfangen zu klatschen oder so? Sie hat mich einmal aufgenaut. Nee, du schnippst dann demonstrativ. Aber waren da gute Pitches dabei? Ja, ja. Aber das darfst du jetzt natürlich nicht sagen. Das ist ja im Vertrauen, weil das wird in den nächsten Jahren die Kinos. Wir haben uns beraten und für mich war es zum ersten Mal. Ich war schon in vielen Situationen, wo eine Jury rausging, um über mich und meine Gruppe ein Urteil zu fällen. Ich war nie in der Position, selber in der Jury zu sein, sich zu beraten, dann zurückzukommen und das Urteil zu verkünden und in aufgeregte Gesichter zu schauen. So, ich war immer auf der anderen Seite, deswegen habe ich mich sehr gefreut, jetzt mal auf der Seite zu sein, ganz toll. Ah, cool. Und dann waren aber zwei Studenten der Veranstalter dabei, also die das Ganze veranstaltet haben, die waren dabei. Und dann haben wir uns so beraten und haben dann auch den Gewinner, das Gewinnerteam festgestellt. Und dann haben wir danach die gefragt, die hat ja auch genommen, die hat gesagt, nee. Was sich für mich angefühlt hat, wir haben die falsche Entscheidung getroffen. Und die Studenten haben die falschen Leute eingeladen. Ja. Alle haben hier auf die falsche Entscheidung getroffen. Alle haben hier die falsche Entscheidung getroffen. Nee, es war aber schon cool. Aber auch schwierig. Auch gerade wenn man immer von der anderen Seite kommt, weiß man ja auch, wie schwierig das jetzt gerade ist und wie lebensentscheidend bezeichnet immer solche Momente sind.
Von daher war es wirklich nicht.
Ich freue mich auf die neuen Filme, die kommen. Jetzt wird ja wahrscheinlich wieder viel produziert, viel gemacht, Leute gehen ins Kino, es geht wieder los, tolle Ideen kommen in die Kinos. Und schau die dritte Staffel von How to Sell Drugs Online Fast mit dem grossartigen, grossartigen Maximilian Mund, aber auch dem unglaublich tollen Flohntin Will, der ja auch eine sehr große Rolle spielt dieses Jahr. Ja, ich freue mich, vielen Dank, auf jeden Fall, schaut es euch an und schaut euch auch die zweite Staffel von I Think You Should Leave an, die jetzt auch dabei ist. Schaut einfach durch, das ist euer Sommer. Wurde mir empfohlen, das ist ein bisschen wie Gute Arbeit. Wow. So wurde das empfohlen.
So wurde das damals gepitcht, glaube ich auch, als sie das gepitcht haben.
Tim Robinson hat gesagt, a little bit like Gute Arbeit Originals.
Do you know Gute Arbeit Originals? We love Gute Arbeit Originals.
We loved it. Something like that, but in English.
We got this.
Gekauft.
Ja, ich glaube, viel wird sich jetzt verändern.
Jetzt gibt es andere Gesprächsthemen nach der Pandemie.
Worüber willst du sprechen?
Viren.
Also im Privat... Du hast jetzt... Du bist in der Hänge gelegt. Ich will so viel wissen über Viren, über Lockdowns.
Aber es ist nichts wert, weil jeder hat dieses ganze Wissen.
Ich weiß, aber ich habe es ja auch und ich will das loswerden. Und ich will es an den Mann bringen.
Vor allem wird jetzt alles nachgeholt, was man verpasst hat während der Pandemie.
Viele Themen sind ja in Hintergrund gerückt, viele Nachrichten sind gar nicht an einen rangekommen, viele wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse sind gar nicht an einen rangekommen.
Welche?
Naja, also ich glaube schon, dass Dinge rausgefunden wurden in der Pandemie, die nicht ans Licht der Öffentlichkeit kamen, weil sich ja gerade niemand dafür interessiert hat.
Das stimmt schon.
Und jetzt gibt es die große Konferenz, wo alle Wissenschaftler in einer Reihe stehen.
Ja, Gravitationsgesetz war Quatsch. Das macht keinen Sinn mehr und Zeit hat keine Relevanz. Das stimmt schon. Und jetzt gibt es die große Konferenz, wo alle Wissenschaftler in einer Reihe stehen und einfach
sagen, Gravitationszusatz war Quatsch.
Das macht keinen Sinn mehr und Zeit hat keine Relevanz.
Ciao! Wir sind nur ein bisschen
untergegangen, weil gerade ein Virus war.
Ja, also wir haben rausgefunden, dass
die Wurzeln von allen Bäumen
miteinander zusammenhängen. Also es gibt
eigentlich nur einen einzigen Baum
auf der Erde. Danke.
Man sollte jetzt eine Veranstaltung machen,
wo alle kurz drankommen.
Und nach dem etabliere ich
in Sekunde eins, dass man klatscht.
Ja, also wir haben rausgefunden,
dass die Erde noch einen zweiten Mond hat,
aber der ist
nur ungefähr so groß.
Die Astronomin zeigt einen
ungefähr Volleyball-grossen Mond.
Volleyball.
Ungefähr so groß, aber er ist da. Dankeschön. Habe ich da erzählt, ich habe diese tolle Doku geguckt über die Erkenntnisse des Schwarzen Lochs, des Roten Donuts, wie wir ihn nennen im Podcast-Uvo. Und ich habe noch eine andere fantastische Doku geschaut. Die war wirklich irre und ich bin ein bisschen late to the party, aber vielleicht kennst du sie auch schon, My Octopus Teacher. Ja, kenn ich. Ich habe mich schon beschwert über den Namen, weil es hieß irgendwie Mein Lehrer der Krake oder so was. Und ich war fuchsteufelswild, ich war rasend über diesen Titel und fand die Doku aber ganz gut eigentlich. Da freundet sich ein Typ mit einem Kraken an. Es ist furchtbar. Und ja, finde ich mal interessant, eine Tierdoku zu haben über ein einzelnes Tier. Weil du kennst ja Tierdokus über Löwen, Hyänen, Eisbären. Aber da geht es halt um ein einziges Tier. Die Kranken sind ja eh super krass. Die können sich überall reinzwängen. Genau, es geht ja darum, dass dieser eine Mensch, der so ein bisschen, ja so einen Sinn des Lebens sucht, neu anfängt, dann anfängt jeden Tag ins Wasser zu gehen. Und er hat, er entwickelt eine Freundschaft, was sehr selten ist, weil ich glaube, diese Tiere lassen sich eh immer oder auch kaum filmen und so, und entwickelt dann eine Freundschaft zu diesem Riesen-Oktopus, die ja unglaublich intelligent ist und sehr sensibel und hoch empathisch und so. Und diese ganze Loco begeistert ihn halt dabei, weil er auch eine Kamera hat und vor allem auch Fotograf war. Super spannend, wie er sich mit dem anfreundet, mit diesem Oktopus und ja auch nicht eingreifen will so richtig, weil er immer das Gefühl hat so, nee, ich muss die Natur schon den Lauf lassen hier irgendwie. Und dieser Oktopus zeigt ihm so ein bisschen sein Leben, wie er Dinge macht. Am Anfang waren Dinge noch Fragen für ihn, am Ende hat er genau verstanden und so hochdramatisch. Und dann sind die irgendwann super doll befreundet. Viele Aspekte fand ich da super lustig auch, weil irgendwann waren die so doll befreundet und der Oktopus hat gesagt, komm, ich zeige dir mal, wie man jetzt jagt. Und dann hat der Oktopus so eine Krabbe gejagt. Und dann hat der Mensch natürlich, er konnte ihm helfen, aber er dachte, nein, kann ich jetzt auch nicht, weil er muss natürlich jetzt selber gucken, dass er jetzt diese Krabbe jagt und so.
Und dann war super spannend, wie der Oktopus auch so super coole Taktiken angewandt hat, um den Weg abzustecken und so.
Und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, wie lustig es wäre, wenn bei der Krabbe auch ein Mensch dranhinge.
Auch ein Freund, ja. Der dich mit der Krabbe angefreundet hat, weil dann kommt es am Ende ja dazu, dass so ein Hai kommt, also Spoiler ein bisschen, aber auch nicht, wird auch schnell gezeigt, und man sich sorgt um diesen Oktopus. Und ich dachte mir jetzt, wer macht jetzt Sorgen um diese Krabbe? Und vielleicht hat diese Krabbe eine Gefreundung mit dem anderen Menschen. Und muss jetzt der Krakenfreund den Krabbenfreund töten und essen? Ja. Muss das dann auch und wir sind basically in Pokémon gefilten. Und wo ist der Freund von dem Hai, der plötzlich, der hat einen Tentakel abgebissen? Ja. Und dann können die immer ein Wort miteinander reden? Aber ich hab mir auch, als ich die Doku gesehen hab, ich glaube, ich habe der Hälfte aufgehört, wirklich zuzugucken, weil sich so viele Filme in meinem Kopf abgespielt haben, wie das jetzt weitergehen kann. Weil ich denke mir natürlich immer, das ist fake und das geht so real weiter. Ich dachte auch, er verlässt seine Familie für den Oktopus. Genau, ich dachte, er verliebt sich in den Oktopus und es wird immer intensiver und irgendwann haben die Sex miteinander. Ja, habe ich auch gedacht. Und es kommen Kinder, dieb Mensch und so Vater, warum hast du uns geboren und die ertrinken aber sofort nach der Geburt. Wir gehen sofort in Shape of Water, also so nahtlos in Shape of Water. Oder dass er auch immer, dass er immer beschreibt so, ja, ich konnte dann auch irgendwann immer länger unter Wasser atmen, irgendwie merkwürdigerweise, meine Lunge hat sich angepasst. Und irgendwann hatte ich so komische, und dann dachte ich immer, hat ein Fall, er verliert seinen Arm, und er wächst aber nach, dachte ich dann. Oder ihm, dem Kranken wird ein Tentakel abgebissen und er verliert in dem Moment seinen Arm, im gleichen Moment. Und er sagt, ja, ganz merkwürdigerweise habe ich meinen Arm auch verloren, aber stattdessen ist ein Tentakel daraus gewachsen. oder so. Und einfach, ich fände es, wenn der diesen normalen, distanzierten Narrationsstil fortgezogen hätte, mit absolut absurden Sachen und irgendwann konnten wir uns unterhalten und ich habe verstehen, was sie mir gesagt haben. Und irgendwann haben sich die Dinge, hat sich meine Familie wie ein Traum angefühlt und es ist ein Wasser wie die Realität. Ja genau. Das fängt so langsam an, so tief, aber irgendwann wird es einfach so weird spooky. Und irgendwann wohnt er einfach bei dem Kraken einfach dann da zu Hause. Aber das fand ich unglaublich lustig, einfach diese Vorstellung, dass da irgendwann einfach so ein anderer Mensch an dieser Krabbe oder diesen Haien hängt. Aber sowas müsste man als Spielfilm machen, oder? Und was ich auch noch lustig fand, war dann, dass dann, kam man irgendwann dahin und der Oktopus hat dann
gespielt mit Fischen.
Also er hat
irgendwann das Jagdverhalten von diesem Oktopus,
wusste genau, wie der jetzt jagt. Aber dann war da so
Fische und hat dann mit denen gespielt.
Und es war so, alles daran war klar,
dass es jetzt ein spielerisches Verhalten war.
Und das Insekten
was hier und der hätte die fangen können und so, hat dann aber mit die so rumgejagt und an nach B, wo ich mir dachte, ah krass, das heißt ja auch, dass Tieren fucking langweilig ist. Und das ändert wiederum alles. Weil ich dachte immer, nein, Tieren ist nie langweilig, weil Tiere haben das Bewusstsein dafür gar nicht so richtig. Tiere folgen einfach ihren Instinkten. Ich muss jetzt schlafen, ich muss jetzt essen, ich muss jetzt schlafen, ich muss jetzt vorpflanzen, ich muss jetzt schlafen.
So, ich dachte, da bleibt kein Platz, da ist auch gar kein Bewusstsein für Langeweile.
Wenn dann dieser Oktopus aber anfängt, sich dann an irgendeinem Punkt einfach hinzusetzen, nichts zu machen, dann zu diesem Stein zu schwimmen, wo diese Fische sind, und mit diesen Fischen zu spielen, weiß ich ja,
bevor er sich entschieden hat, zu diesen Fischen zu gehen und mit denen zu spielen, gab es
einen Moment von
Puh.
Machst du Blasen?
Mal alle
durchzählen, nur noch sieben Tentakel.
Dann irgendwann mal macht er diese
Saugnäpfe an sich dran und macht
die so nacheinander auf und zu. Oder saugt die Tentakel so aneinander und zieht sie wieder weg. Ja, so Klettverschlussmässig. Ja. Du machst dann dreimal und sagst dann, das kann doch kein Tag sein. Das ist mein Tag? Boah, es ist 14 Uhr erst. Ich schau mal, was die Fische machen. Ja, und dann spielt er mit diesen Fischen. Ich denke mir, sobald ein Fisch, sobald ein Tier mit anderen Tieren spielt, gab es davor einen Moment der Langeweile. Und checken die Fische, dass er nur spielt, oder hat er Spaß daran, die Fische zu ärgern? Nein, die haben Todesangst. Ah, ah, ah! Von A nach B. Ja, schon verrückt, ne? Aber ich glaube, so Kaken sind, das ist ja auch ultraintelligent. Die Frage ist, was heißt das immer genau? Und die haben zwei Herzen, ne? Aber ich glaube, so Kaken sind, also das ist ja auch ultraintelligent. Die Frage ist, was heißt das immer genau? Weil am Ende... Und die haben zwei Herzen, ne? Eins für Anime und eins für ihr Leben, oder was? Oder wie? Es schlagen zwei Herzen in ihrer Brust. Wie meinst du das? Ne, eins im Kopf und eins im, weiß ich nicht wo, aber die haben auch... Aber hat nicht jede Tentakel ein eigenes Gehirn, irgendwie sowas? Mein Gott, halt irgendwelche Fakten, das könnt ihr euch auch selber ausdenken. Mein Gott, es ist halt so, da werden halt 20 Fakten genannt. Crazy Fakten hier. Ja, halt, es ist doch egal, was der Fakt ist. Der Inhalt von Fakten ist egal, Fakten sind auch nur Unterhaltung. Das ist einfach wie so ein Bonbon fürs Gehirn. Du wirst es und sagst, hm, lecker. Ja, die Fakten wären euch egal. Scheißegal. Aber der Fakt, dass wir jetzt sehr viele Fakten aufzählen würden, sag ich doch, die sind einfach krasse Tiere. Ja, die sind krass da. Die Botschaft muss ja wohl angekommen sein. Ja, die haben nur einen Schnabel, der ist das Einzige, was hart ist, der Rest ist weich oder halt andersrum. Ist doch egal. Das ist doch wirklich interessant. Auch diese unnützen Fakten, da geht es nicht um Inhalte, sondern einfach um so ein kurzes Aha, okay. Ja, krass. Ach krass, hätte ich jetzt ja gar nicht gedacht. Das ist wie so ein Witz, den man sich erzählt. Oh, ich habe letztens. Also ich glaube, wir sind ja beide keine Riesenfans von ich erzähle jetzt mal ein Witz. Von klassischen Witzen. Von klassischen kommt ein Mann zum Arzt Witzen. Ich kenne auch keinen. Ich kenne null. Aber ich war ja unterwegs mit meinen Freunden im Urlaub. Und da gibt es ja unterschiedliche Comedy-Erwartungen. Also nicht jeder hat beruflich mit Comedy zu tun und so und man da heißt okay, jemand erzählt einen Witz. Und ich glaube, ich bin in eine der der lustigsten Witzsituationen geraten, die ich in meinem Leben hatte mit diesem Witz. Und ich bin noch nicht da ganz am Ende ihn entschlüsselt zu haben. Und dann waren so ein paar Witze und ein paar Leute haben Witz erzählt und dann hat einer so, ja niemand erinnert sich an Witz und dann so, ah ja doch, ich habe einen, aber der ist nicht so gut. Und zwar, wisst ihr, warum sich die Waldraut nicht in Waldraut? Damit sie der Herbert nicht herbehrt. Und alle so, was?
Und der Witz erzählt, er hat nur so, ja, ich habe ja gesagt, er ist nicht so gut. Das war diese, diese vollkommene Verwirrung auf allen Ebenen. Und diese Erklärung, ich hätte ja gesagt, er ist nicht so gut, die aber super unzufriedenstellend ist, weil sie nicht erklärt, was da gerade vorgefallen ist.
Niemand versteht, was gerade passiert ist.
Das ist wie jemand, der auf dem Fahrrad steigt und das Fahrrad kippt sofort um und er sagt danach, ich habe ja gesagt, dass ich nicht so gut Fahrrad fahren kann.
Das erklärt nicht, was davor passiert ist.
Was bis dahin passiert sein muss.
Dieser Mensch hat den Witz mal gehört, fand ihn nicht gut und hat ihn wahrscheinlich auch nicht verstanden, hat ihn sich aber gemerkt und in der Situation sich dazu entschlossen, ihn zu erzählen mit dem Wissen, dass er ihn wahrscheinlich selber nicht verstanden hat oder falsch gehört hat und ihn trotzdem erzählt mit, aber er ist nicht so gut.
Der Witz ist, finde ich, auch herausragend konstruiert,
weil wisst ihr, warum sich die Waltrautnischen Waltraut ist?
Perfekt. Der Name und die Erfahrung ist perfekt.
Und ich weiss genau, was mich erwartet jetzt.
Genau, du weisst, worauf du hast.
Ja gut, es wird ein Wortspiel sein.
Und so gut, wie Waltraut sich Waltraut ist,
so schlecht ist, damit sie der Herbert nicht Herbert. Jeder weiß, jetzt kommt irgendwas Zotiges, Sexuelles, aber... Hast du nicht bessere Namen? Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich verstehe es null. Und es kann sein, dass es... Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es eine Dialektfrage ist. Ich glaube, es ist so nah dran. Vielleicht, also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass Leute sagen, nein, das und das meint er. Und es ist ein normaler Witz, aber Helmut vielleicht? Aber was? Weißt du, Helmut, Helmut. Weil es gibt kein, vor allem das Lustige ist. Lass mal auf bayerisch Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Es gibt wahrscheinlich tausende Begriffe für, was weiß ich, für Sex haben im Dialekt, von denen ich wahrscheinlich viele nicht kenne, auch im bayerischen oder irgendwas in der Art. Oder mit der Herbert, die Herbert. Also es kann sein, dass viele Bayern jetzt vielleicht sagen, ja, ist doch klar, was es heißt, aber ich sehe es nicht. Aber das Geile ist, vor allem das Lustige an der Situation war nicht, dass Leute aus einem Meter, weil du hast ja gelacht, als du den Gag gehört hast, weil er so anti-witzig war. Aber das war gar nicht die Situation. Die Leute haben wirklich nur gesagt, was meinst du? Natürlich verstehe ich es nicht. Das war so lustig. Des Lachens. Und ich habe mich kaputt gedacht. Ich fand es so... Ach, hast du dich so auch kaputt bin bis heute, ich bin bis heute, denke ich an diesen Witz, weil er so fantastisch ist. Aber er wahrscheinlich auch. Er wahrscheinlich auch. Wo du mal irgendwann in diese Situation kommst, wo gefragt wird, hat der Witze und du durch den ganzen sozialen Druck dein Gehirn einfach scheitest. Ja genau, auf Herbert. Fuck Herbert. Fuck, ich erzähl Herbert. Er ist nicht so gut.
Er ist nicht so gut, aber ich
fand ihn noch nie so gut, aber ich
habe mir nichts anderes gemerkt.
Das ist herausragend, die Erklärung.
Ich habe ja gesagt, er ist nicht so gut.
Nee, das Problem ist nicht, dass er
nicht gut ist. Das Problem ist, dass
er von Jitzen bis vorne nicht
funktioniert.
Es streng genommen nicht mein Witz ist, es ist falsch nacherzählt. Es fehlen Wörter. Ah, herrlich. Ich muss immer wieder daran denken. Es ist kurz davor, das zu googeln. Du kannst danach gerne googeln. Vielleicht ist es irgendwie falsch erzählt, aber ich finde den fantastisch. Das ist ab jetzt wirklich ernsthaft mein neuer Lieblingswitz. Weil ich glaube, vor allem Leute, die Bock auf diesen Meta-Humor haben, kriegt man damit einfach direkt, weil es ist so, weil Herbert ist so schön, weil es hat, man kann sich schon vorstellen, dass das irgendwas bedeutet, aber man kommt nicht drauf. Nee, es sagt nicht direkt, das ist ein Quatschgag. Genau. Es ist auf der Art, es es so ein guter Metagag, weil er die
Vorsilbe her sogar
Sinn ergibt. Genau. Weil man weiß ja schon,
was kommt. Jetzt kommt irgendwas Schlüpferiges.
Es ist so close,
dieser Witz. Ist so kurz vor einem Witz.
Aber das Verb Bärt ist halt
Was? Also, grossartig.
Also, falls ihr auch mal in die Situation kommt,
einen Witz zu erzählen und ihr habt nichts, hier habt ihr einen von mir. Ich kann nicht auch darüber nachzudenken, Herr kann ja schon die erste Silbe sein. Aber ich habe dann auch nachgedacht, welcher andere Name könnte er vielleicht verwechselt haben. Du hast dann nach dem Wasser nicht mehr so gebraucht. Er war wachgelegen nachts. Herr? Damit er nicht Heinre oder Reinhardt, weiß ich nicht. Heinrich? Das hat auch gar keine Sinn. Aber es ist grossartig. Also falls euch was einfällt, schreibt es gerne, aber grossartig. Pass auf, wir reichen nächste Woche nach, wie es eigentlich heißt. Ja. Wir reichen auf jeden Fall nächste Woche nach, wie der Eigentlichheit. G Gag-Ersatz nicht. Ihr googelt nicht, ist die Regel. Aber wie wir das bei unserem Flutter-Karibik-Übersetzungs-Gag gemacht haben, reicht ihr Gags ein, die hier passen könnten. Die besten Pointen sind die, auf die man eine Woche wartet. Weiss, glaube ich, jeder. Die besten Pointen sind die, auf denen man eine Woche lang rumgrübelt. Und dann zu einem unbefriedigenden Ergebnis vor allem, wo die raushaut und alle sagen, was, ach für den Witz. Also, ich freue mich jetzt schon drauf. Mega. Ich habe gesagt, er ist nicht so gut. Ich habe gesagt, er ist nicht so gut. Aber die Person, die dir erzählt hat, ist ja auch einmal jetzt in so ein soziales Fettnäpfchen getreten, weil allein, weil die Person weiß ja auch, dass es kein Sinn ergibt. Ist ja nicht so, dass diese Person sieht darin ja nicht einen Witz. Das ist, weil das Lustigste an der Situation ist der Gedankenszustand dieser Person, weil ich meine, jeder kennt Witze, wo man sagt, die sind nicht so super lustig und vielleicht kennen die schon alle, aber eigentlich ist es schon eine titanische soziale Leistung, einen Witz zu erzählen, von dem man weiß, nicht, dass er nicht lustig ist, sondern dass er schlicht nicht funktioniert. Ich glaube, das weiss die Person nicht. Diese Person hat den auch nicht verstanden einfach. Aber dass du nicht mal nachgefragt hast, das zeigt wirklich, dass du soziale Intergression 2 hast, weil mein erster Gedanke wäre, erklär mir jetzt mal, wie du denkst, dieser Witz funktioniert. Ja, genau, habe ich ja gefragt, was meinst du denn? Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, er ist nicht gut. Und das hast du akzeptiert als Antwort auf die Frage? Ja, ja, ja. Ach, grossartig. Aber die haben schon ihre Berechtigung, diese klassische Kommt-Mann-zum-Arzt-Gags, weil einfach die Erwartungshaltung so stark ist. Und damit kann man, glaube ich, viel machen.
Ich bin so angestrengt, wenn man in dieses, wir erzählen uns jetzt Witze-Ding fällt.
Weil zum einen habe ich die Angst, ich werde gleich nach einem Witz gefragt, mir fällt keiner ein, und ich bin kurz dafür, Herbert zu erzählen.
Das ist Angst eins. Angst zwei ist, ich muss an der richtigen Stelle jetzt lachen und der Witz ist schon viel zu lang, wird er gerade erzählt und ich habe nichts zugehört mehr. Heißt, mein Lachen ist eh fake. Fake, fake, fake, fake, fake, fake. Ja. Und das muss ich an der richtigen Stelle platzieren, sonst fällt das auf. Ja. Nee, ist schwierig. Ist wirklich schwierig. Man sollte einfach nie in die Situation kommen. Nee, deswegen bin ich auch gegen diese ausgedachten Witze. Ich war mal im Podcast zu Gast, wo ich so einen Witz erzählen sollte am Ende des Podcasts, und mir ist keiner eingefallen. Und er hat mich auch nicht losgelassen. Er hat dann auch nicht gesagt so, okay, alles Teil, ich werde keiner ein. Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, da haben wir hier Ines Aiole zu Gast. Nein, es war, er hat mich nicht losgelassen. Es wurde richtig unangenehm. Es wurde unangenehm, weil er mich gedrängt zu einem Witz. Zwanzig Minuten lang hat er gesagt, wir hören jetzt hier nicht auf. Friedemann Karich hat mich einfach bestimmt fünf Minuten dazu gedrängt, einen Witz zu erzählen. Hat dich mit seiner Comedy-Tentakel um den Knöchel geschlungen und dich unter Wasser gezogen. Aber es war ja kein Kukettier, mir ist ja wirklich keiner eingefallen. Mir ist keiner eingefallen. Kein Witz. Und ich habe ja schon viele gehört, aber das soll ich dann erzählen. Ich habe eine Filmszene nacherzählen können, aber es war ja nicht gefragt. Es war ein klassischer Witz, wurde gefragt. Erzählen sich Tiere Witze? Gibt es sowas? Tiere spielen mit Fischen, Tieren ist langweilig. Aber wie traurig ist dieser Gedanke, dass Tieren langweilig sind? Das ist fast noch schlimmer, als dass sie Schmerz verspüren. Aber das Problem ist, es ist nicht wessen Schuld ist, dass Tiere langweilig sind. Die leben, wie sie leben sollen. Aber ich fühle mich ein bisschen schuldig. Das ist mir oft aufgefallen. Ich bin so sensibel, ich will mal, dass allen Menschen und jetzt auch Tieren um mich herum, dass es denen gut geht. Bislang dachte ich zu Hunden, denn die haben schon eine gute Zeit. Denen geht es schon gut. Die haben halt drei Aufgaben in ihrem Kopf und die arbeiten sie nacheinander ab, okay. Aber jetzt kommt hinzu, vielleicht ist es ihnen langweilig.
Und ich muss sie bespaßen. Ich muss mich, jetzt muss ich, ist im Prinzip eine neue Aufgabe in meinem Leben dazugekommen, ich muss jetzt auch Tiere bespassen, Tiere ein gutes Gefühl geben.
Es gibt DogTV.
Es gibt DogTV und ich finde, Mann, ich habe leider das Problem, also das Schlimmste, das kennt ja jeder, man hat irgendwie ein YouTube-Video gesehen und man verliert es, es flutscht einen durch die Grifflinge und ist weg im Sumpf des Internets. Und dann versucht man es zu finden mit irgendwelchen Suchbegriffen und es kommt einfach nicht, man findet es nicht mehr. Und noch viel schlimmer ist, wenn man so ein TikTok verliert oder so diese Kurzvideos, TikTok oder Instagram Reels, bei die sind in der Regel nahezu nicht getaggt, es gibt keine guten Suchen und man findet die einfach nicht mehr. Und eines meiner absoluten Lieblingssachen, die ich auch dir gerne geschickt hätte, war ein Hund, der Dog-TV schaut.
Und es geht um tanzende Früchte, anscheinend ist die heutige Folge, sind tanzende Früchte.
Und du hast erst so tanzende Himbeeren, die da so hin und her wackeln, die Himbeeren und der Hund guckt sich das an, dann kommen so tanzende Bananen, hin und her, gelb, flackernes Licht, der Hund guckt sich das an, dann kommen die tanzenden Blaubeeren und der Hund rastet aus, der Hund bellt den Fernseher an, ist nicht mehr zur Ruhe zu kriegen, springt auf links nach rechts und dann kommen wieder die ganzen Erdbeeren und er ist wieder gecheckt. Anscheinend hat dieser Hund keinen Bock auf Blaubeeren und die müssen raus und die sind seit fünf Staffeln überfällig und der Charakter hat sich totgelaufen und der muss weg. Aber ich finde, es sind gerade überlegt, was ein menschliches Pendant dazu ist, aber so emotional gucken wir gar nicht Fernsehen. Vielleicht, keine Ahnung, wenn bei Game of Thrones irgendwas passiert, was man nicht gut findet und dann, oh nein, oh nein, aber so ist es für die die Blaubeeren. Der ist da wirklich dabei. Oder waren die Blaubeeren von vornherein in der Staffel 1, als Bösewichte erzählt? Ich habe die, wie gesagt, die Staffeln davor nicht gesehen. Es waren auch einfach tanzende Blaubeeren. Es waren auch tanzende Blaubeeren. Für den menschlichen Betrachter kein Unterschied. Nein? Aber für den hundischen Betrachter, den die Staffel davor gesehen hat. Da hatten die so böse Augen, die so runtergucken und die haben die Äpfel vertrieben und so. Ne, die waren super fröhlich. Auch fröhliche, rasselnde, bach. Super fröhlich tanzende Blaubeeren, genauso viele, alles klar. Aber da dachte ich mir auch, wow, der ist da wirklich in dieses Programm wirklich emotional verhaftet, also der schaut das wirklich an, wie ein Mensch irgendeine Lieblingsserie sehen würde und ist wirklich wütend und oh, den Charakter hasse ich. Aber das macht sehr noch schwieriger jetzt für mich, der jetzt auch noch Tiere bespassen muss, aber die auch nicht mit allem bespaßen kann, weil ich,
mein erster Gedanke wäre gewesen, Blaubeeren.
Ja, klar,
das dachten viele.
Aber hat man dem Hund mal jetzt Blaubeeren hingelegt und überguckt, was in der echten Welt passiert?
Das weiß ich nicht. Wie gesagt, ich hätte gerne mehr
über diesen Hund gelernt und seinen Hass auf Blaubeeren,
woher der kommt, aber ich finde leider
dieses TikTok nicht. Falls ihr es findet, schickt es mir
gerne, ich würde da gerne mehr darüber berichten. Empfiehlt Florentin will TikTok? Entschuldige, das frage ich bereits gerne. Empfiehlt Florentin will TikTok? Tut es, aber es ist schon schwierig. Nee, will ich hochstehen? Achso, nee, ich gucke das ja immer über Instagram Reels und das ist das Schlimmste, dass wenn man den Account nicht mal findet, sondern es nur ein TikTok-Account ist, der gespielt wird. Dass du das neue Medium über dein altes Medium konsumierst, woran du dich bereits gewöhnt hast, mit deinen dicken Fingern. Ich kriege auch Tweets nur über Lochkarten nach Hause einfach. Ich kann die ansonsten nicht lesen. Aber es ist die Frage, wessen Verantwortung ist es, dass es dir nicht langweilig ist, weil du kannst nicht alles machen, du kannst ein Haus füttern.
Ich würde sagen, die Erde.
Ich stelle dir mal die Erde wie so ein Ferienresort vor.
Kommt hierher, hier ist immer was los.
So ein Planet, der hat, ich habe hier Sandwelten, ich habe hier Australien, ich habe hier Gas, Eiswelten, ja, Vulkan. Eiswelten gepackt, warme Welten, grüne Welten, kalte Welten, so.
Und da macht auf mir Urlaub, lebt bei mir, lebt auf mir.
Das ist der Clame der Erde?
Lebt auf mir, wo wollt ihr denn sonst hin?
So, das ist der Clame der Erde.
Und jetzt sind die Tiere draufgepflanzt und sind so...
Puh, jo. draufgepflanzt und sind so
macht dann der Oktopus mit seinem der hat sich viele Finger reingesteckt in die Noppen. Wollen wir noch eine Krabbe essen? Puppenvoll auch. Naja, wir hatten ja gerade erst eine, ne?
Und wir sind streng genommen ja alleine unterwegs.
Der Hai, der uns ...
Hat uns gejagt, aber es war ja auch schon zwei Monate her. Sind die da jetzt noch in der Nähe? Vielleicht mal zu verstecken? Angst haben oder sowas? Ne, ich glaube nicht. Ich würde dann kurz meine Farbe anpassen an den Stein hier. Brauchst du dafür irgendwie Hilfe oder kannst du einfach so machen?
Nee, ich habe da Fotosensoren, die sich direkt anpassen.
Ist das ein Kraftakt für dich?
Null, überhaupt nicht.
Passiert wie von selbst.
Das wäre ja eigentlich gar nicht erwähnenswert.
Nee, ich wollte nur kurz sagen, nicht, dass du denkst, ich bin weg, ich bin noch hier.
Ich würde jetzt nur die Farbe ändern.
Ich dachte jedes Mal beim Gucken so, man sieht schon noch, dass es ein Ziel ist. Aber es ist keine schlechte Frage, weiss der Krake, in welcher Farbe er gerade ist? Oder passen die sich wirklich automatisch an? Das Geile ist ja, es gibt da Videos, und das ist wirklich insane, wo ich dachte kurz, mir wird die nicht langweilig auf dir, wow, wenn man die Träumen sieht. Oh ja, und dann flackern die Sohne. Und die ändern die Farben. Das ist verrückt. Aber das geht mir zu weit. Das finde ich es gruselig. Ich finde es auch gruselig. Die Träumen, aber die träumen jetzt immer nur von Dingen, die sie kennen, offensichtlich. Wohingegen, wenn ich meine Farbe anpassen würde, von den Dingen, die ich träume, ist ja manchmal auch abstrakter Shit, dann wäre ich so ein Greenscreen plötzlich, wäre ich komplett grün. Die hingegen sind ja immer nur leicht anders, weil jetzt träumen die von Korallen, dann werden sie rot. Aber wie süss ist sie von Korallen. Aber ich meine zum Beispiel, der Mensch hatte ja, der Vorfahrer vom Mensch war ja irgendein Affe, der hatte ja überall Haare. Und dann ist der Mensch sich weiterentwickelt und hat die meisten Haare verloren, hat nur noch an manchen Stellen Haaren, aber an vielen nicht mehr. Wie ist es denn jetzt, wenn der Krake sich weiterentwickelt und irgendwann Kleidung trägt, kann er dann auch nur noch an den Stellen, die sozusagen nackt sind, die Farbe verändern oder überall oder im Gesicht? Nur im Gesicht die Farbe ändern, ja. Oder wie funktioniert das? Wie geil. Das wäre wirklich so ein Asset am Menschen, was ich mega finde. Aber ist es nicht total verschwendet, wenn du ihr Kleidung trägst, dass du dann noch den Rest dein, weil du hast ein rotes T-Shirt an, du kannst dich vor der Hecke so grün machen, wie du willst mit deiner Haut, du hast ein rotes T-Shirt an. Für Instagram wäre es doch mega. Aber können die generell immer nur die Farbe annehmen von etwas, was hinter ihnen ist oder wenn sie geträumen zum Beispiel auch? Ich glaube, die haben so drei Slots, wo sie so gewisse Farbschemata speichern können, aber die müssen sie immer wieder auffrischen. Ich dachte gerade, wenn sie träumen und die nehmen die Farbe an, dann ist es ja nicht wichtig, dass sie an dem Ort sind, sondern es ist wichtig, dass sie daran denken an dem Ort. Ja. Also du denkst, oh, die sind auf Rainbow Road und deswegen macht der Körper automatisch die Regenbogenfarben an. Das wird ja beweisen. Wenn er träumt, der Maulwurf, vielleicht was soll. Weit, weit gegriffen, dass der denkt, er wäre irgendwo und deswegen hat er die Farbe. Ich kann auch einfach sagen, dass der wie, wenn du so ein gewisser so ein Rechner anmachst oder eine Tastatur, dann leuchten die manchmal in allen Farben auf, bevor es losgeht, damit die einfach mal alles durchtesten. Damit die sehen, geht noch alles. Die träumen ja dann und dann sind sie rot. Und dann weiss man aber, okay, er ist manchmal in der Nähe von diesen Korallen, macht es schon Sinn, dass er auch rot sein kann. Heißt, die speichern das ja ab. Ist ja nicht, dass sie davor, dass die Haut das abtastet, die Farbe und dann... Gut, aber jetzt musst du die Gehirnströme analysieren und gucken, hat er immer, wenn er rot ist, ähnliche Gehirnströme? Sieht es dann ähnlich aus im Gehirn, wenn er denkt, er ist da? Oder ist es nur so eine Art, die Farbe, die er den Tag über am wenigsten genutzt hat, muss er im Schlaf mal aktivieren, damit das nicht ... Die muss raus. Die muss raus, aber das ist ja auch, wenn du deinen linken Arm mehr trainierst als den rechten, ist es falsch. Deswegen, im Schlaf holt dein Körper das nach. Ich dachte gerade, ah okay, das ist ein bisschen wie bei Jumper, dem Film, Hayden Christensen, überall, wo man schon mal war. Es haben weniger Leute den Film gesehen, als dass du es schon im Podcast erwähnt hast. Fucking Jumper. In der zweiten Folge. Ja, bei Jumper ist die Prämisse. Und es macht es auch nicht besser, wenn du sagst, oh, der muss ich sehen. Ja, doch, für uns Star Wars Fans. Aber ich meine, da ist die Prämisse, man muss schon mal da gewesen sein. Und dann kann man hinjumpen wieder. Ja. So funktioniert man danach. Ja, haben die automatisch alle Farben freigeschaltet? Nein! Du müsstest eigentlich mal ein Tintenfischkind isolieren und nur in einem Braunton oder so Herbst, also so erdige Herbsttöne. Erdige Wes Anderson Herbsttöne. Genau, Wes Anderson und nur Wes Anderson Filme zeigen den ganzen Tag. Pastell.
Pastellfilme.
Und dann gucken, ob er auch andere Farben kann.
Dann gibst du dem so einen Neonmarker und pass dich mal an den an, ob er das kann oder nicht.
So, oder hat er alles schon eingespeichert? Ich dachte gerade, wenn wir Menschen nur unser Gesicht ändern könnten in Farben.
Aber nur an Orten, die wir schon kennen, wo wir schon mal waren.
Ja.
Wie geil.
Ist das nützlich denn? Ich war neulich in Paris. Auch mit Musik muss er noch zumindest dabei sein. Klar, die Nase füllt in so eine Musik. Aber das heißt, du kannst dann da so Sachen zeigen. Ich will dir auch nicht, wenn mir jemand von seinem Urlaub erzählt, will ich noch nicht von der Stirn mir die Bilder angucken. Es kannst dir auf meiner Stirn... Es ist doch grauenvoll genug, sich die Dia so anzugucken vom Urlaub. Auf meiner Stirn kannst du die Filme angucken. Das ist ein absoluter Albtraum. Aber so wie ich mich an sie erinnere. Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres, sich Urlaubsfotos von irgendjemand anzugucken. Und wenn ich der Person dann auch ständig ins Gesicht gucken muss, die meine Enttäuschung ablesen kann aus zehn Zentimeter... Ich sehe dich genau. Meine Augen können ja gucken. Da wart ihr? Wow! Aha. So, und jetzt zeige ich dir dasselbe Bild vom Eiffelturm noch achtzig Mal. Nee, man kann die schlechten ja löschen davon, also am Kopf, iPad. Nee, aber ich kann dir zum Beispiel auch Filmszenen zeigen. Nee, ich habe es nämlich so in Erinnerung. Und dann kann ich dir die Szene zeigen von der Hochzeit von Marie, wo wir uns kennengelernt haben. Marie ist in die Torte gefallen. Wo ich, aber jetzt habe ich unser Streitgespräch nämlich so in Erinnerung und dann kann ich es dir zeigen. Aber kann Marie nicht sagen, nein, das Streitgespräch lief so ab und dann muss ich bei euch von den Stirn hin und her gucken. Wie die Tiltabys, haben es doch. Ach Gott, das ist ja schrecklich. Wo auf deren Bauch. Furchtbar. Aber du hast doch gestern zu mir gesagt, ich wäre inkonsequent. Und dann so. Und dann läuft oben auf meiner Stirn es ab. Du sagst mir jeden Tag, dass ich inkonsequent bin. Und du dann so auf meiner Stirn, ach Gott, sehe ich komisch aus, wenn ich sauer bin. Ist es dein Spiegel verkehrt auf der Stirn? Das hört das mir noch nie so, dass es so schlecht an mir aussieht. Ich bin so froh, dass der Mensch vom Affen abgestammt und nicht vom Tintenfisch und den ganzen weirden Scheiss auch noch mit drin hätte. Aber ist es nicht der erste Schritt zur Zivilisation, Langeweile? Weil wenn der langweilig ist, dann schweift dein Geist, dann kommst du auf den und lass mal den Stock und den Stock zusammensetzen. Guck mal, wir sind ja jetzt entstanden am Ende der Evolution. Jedes Mal, wenn du über Evolution geredet hast, haben Leute kommentiert, dass du es falsch verstehst. Aber ich liest ja nicht, du liest die ja immer. Und du liest die Kommentare nicht und du lernst nicht weiter. Willst du wirklich nochmal denselben Rüffel haben? Nee, anderer. Ich gehe jetzt in eine andere Richtung, andere Rüffel. Gut, gut. So, wir sind vom Affen abgestammt. Und das hat jetzt ungefähr, wie viele Millionen Jahre gedauert? Ja, 20. So was. So, und jetzt lass mal die Erde noch ein bisschen um die Sonne drehen, paar Jahrtausende. Warum, wer sagt denn nicht, dass die nächst cleverere Spezies, der Oktopus, gibt dem mal jetzt noch ein bisschen anpassen und Mutation und bla bla bla und Survival of the fittest, bis der aus dem Wasser kommt und zum nächsten, also wie lange sind wir noch alleine die cleverste Spezies, bis mal was Neues kommt?
Aber meinst du nicht, würden die tottreten? Angenommen, es gäbe wirklich den Fall,
wie kommen wir, wenn die an Land kommen wie wir, dass die wirklich an Land kommen und anfangen, Feuer zu machen und man wirklich, also noch während unserer Lebzeiten wirklich sehen kann, holy crap, das werden die nächsten Menschen. Die können noch nicht reden und so und es dauert noch eine Million Jahre, aber das ist abzusehen. Holy crap. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein Fluch von Tintenfischen. Da kommen Tintenfische und Menschen zusammen. Holy crap. Und die so, ja man, holy crap. That's what we used to say, man. Ich glaube, der Mensch würde irgendwann anfangen, die auszurotten. Als es deine These, pass auf, lieber Stefan, es gibt quasi, wenn man sich Planeten von außen anschaut, kann es maximal eine clevere Spezies auf diesem Planeten geben. Ich weiß nicht, ob clever der richtige wissenschaftliche Ausdruck ist, aber... Es gibt eine fuchsteufelswilde Spezies auf pfiffige... Bleib bei pfiffig. Es kann eine pfiffige Spezies auf dem Planeten geben. Nicht mehr, weil jede pfiffige würde die etwas weniger pfiffige Spezies zerstören. Und angenommen Aliens... Oder versklaven, das kann man natürlich auch machen. Angenommen, Aliens würden uns besuchen. Ja. Dann würde das Gleiche ja dann dafür zutreffen. Ja, aber gut, wir sind ja jetzt schon recht weit. Dann kämen es eher wieder zum Krieg. Aliens, die mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit hier ankommen. Aber hat da jemand ein Auge drauf? Also gibt es nicht irgendeine Behörde, die sagt, hey, guck mal in den Teich, ob es da mal so einen Fisch gibt, der so Beine hat und der so kurz davor ist, an Land zu kommen. Wenn der an Land kommt, Harpune rein. Das ist so eine Behörde mit einem Mitarbeiter. Und einer Harpune.
Wir haben einen Mitarbeiter und drei Harpune.
Eine Harpune.
Und dann können mal besorgte Anwohner anrufen.
Herr Tietze, Herr Tietze, wir haben hier einen Fisch mit Beinen gesehen, in Unterorlach.
Ich bin in drei Minuten da.
Meine Harpune ist geladen.
Das war der Slogan.
Jetzt machen mich Leute darauf aufmerksam, dass das kein guter Slogan ist. Stefan Tietze, meine Harpune ist geladen. Das war der Slogan. Und dann machen mich Leute darauf aufmerksam, dass das kein guter Slogan ist. Stefan Tietzsch, meine Harpune ist geladen. Und Leute so. Warum ruft hier niemand an? Funfact ist der einzige Grund, warum man eine komische Behörde überhaupt kennt, ist, weil die Bild-Zeitung einen grossen Artikel darüber gemacht hat. Genau, und es ging auf Nein-Gang hoch und runter.. Meine Harpune ist geladen, hat dann doch das Gefühl, dass man mich kennt. Ja, du hast es mittlerweile schon geändert, aber auf deinem Auto steht es noch drauf. Ich kriege es nicht ab. Dein Budget ist halt super klein. Aber du konntest dir das Tizemobil leisten mit der Harpune oben drauf. Auch hier ist meine Harpune geladen, meine grosse Harpune. Und damit fährst du jetzt nach Unterorlach. Ich fähre mit meiner grossen
Harpune nach Unterorlach und
baller die Leute weg. Nee,
den Fisch mit Beinen. Ja, ja, dieses Fisch mit Beinen
weg. Diese Scheißbehörde.
Ein Riesenfehler.
Das würde ich jetzt noch machen.
Also ich finde es immer schade, dass wenn Politiker,
deren Amtszeit zu Ende geht,
wie jetzt eine nicht näher genannte
Kanzlerin,
warum die nicht einfach mal noch, einfach mal
draufhauen, einfach sagen, weißt du was, wir gründen
Vielen Dank. deren Amtszeit zu Ende geht, wie jetzt eine nicht näher genannte Kanzlerin, warum die nicht einfach mal noch, einfach mal draufhauen, einfach sagen, weißt du was, wir gründen einfach ein Pokestick-Ministerium, das einfach guckt, dass die nicht zu hoch springen, weil ich hab da, mich nervt's, mich nervt's, einfach mal solche Sachen raushauen und gucken, was noch geht. Aber ich glaube, da hat niemand ein Auge drauf und ich finde es gut, dass wir da mal jetzt drauf aufmerksam machen, weil Tiere, Tiere machen, was sie wollen. Das stimmt eigentlich. Die machen da unten, was sie wollen. Das dachte ich mir die ganze Zeit, als er da mal geguckt hat, was sie da so machen, da war ich froh, dass mal jemand da guckt, dass er ein Auge drauf hat, ja. Weil ich dachte, da ist der Ding, die können ja machen, was sie wollen da unten. Das ist ja komplett hier. Das ist komplett Mayhem, Chaos. Komplett vogelfrei unter Wasser. Die machen da links, rechts, die fressen. Wenn die sagen, ich frisse heute drei Krabben, dann frissen die drei Krabben auf. Dann bin ich froh, dass er sich seine Flossen angezogen hat, tief Luft geholt hat und zwölf Minuten untergetaucht ist. Ach, da war so viele Fragezeichen nach dem. Loco sollten doch eigentlich Fragezeichen im Kopf auflösen und zu punkten, mindestens zu punkten.
Aber greifen die denn zumindest auf, äh ein?
Also ich meine, die Tierdoku irgendwie, wir kennen alle, der Löwe rennt in der Gazelle her, man sagt, oh, rette die Gazelle oder so.
Aber in anderen Situationen, dass der Dokumentarfilmer nicht eingreift, wenn die irgendwie so ein Tier nerven oder mobben und er einfach so, hau ab jetzt da, lass den in Ruhe, wenn da so ein Affe kommt und irgendwie so einen Geparden ärgert, dass er dann sagt, hau ab jetzt da, lass den in Ruhe, dass da einfach mal jemand ein Auge drauf hat und ihm einfach mal so auf die Schnauze drauf haut und so, hau auf jetzt, lass das mal. Ja, genau, bei Hunden macht man das ja auch. Nee, die kann das nicht aufs Sofa. Bei wilden Tieren, die können machen, was sie machen. Da ist teilweise ein Bär in einem Vorgarten. Deswegen sagt man, sag mal, hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden? Sag mal, tickst du noch ganz richtig? Was machst du hier in dem Vorgarten? Raus hier! Und der Bär so, und der Bär so, ja, sorry, sorry, ich wusste nicht, dass ich nicht rein darf. Und dann trottete er von. Herbärt. Bär? Nee. Was ist auch? Bären, es gibt manche Tiere gibt es als Verben, Schlängel. Herbärt vielleicht? Herbärt? Das sind die nicht Herbärt. Weil jetzt haben wir einen Satz. Jetzt haben wir keinen funktionierenden Satz, aber wir haben zum ersten Mal einen Satz. Also H-I-R-B, Leerzeichen, I-H-R-T, Herb-ehrt. Ja, weil er sie Herb-ehrt. Ja, das wird sein, das wird die Lösung sein. Damit sie der Herbert nicht herb ehrt. Der ist jetzt gut damit, jetzt ist er tatsächlich gut. Der ist auf eine Art noch schlechter geworden. Herbert ehrt herb. Weißt du, was ich glaube? Aber ich glaube, wir sind jetzt der Lösung ein bisschen näher gekommen, dass man ja auch, man muss ja nicht da, wo die Silben aufhören, trennen, weißt du? Man kann ja, jetzt habe ich ja zumindest, in gewisser Weise sind die Karten ja jetzt neu gemischt. Du hast das Leerzeichen verschoben, das hast du gut gemacht. Die Karten sind neu gemischt, aber es sind immer noch alles null. Die Vorzeichen sind die gleichen, aber die Karten sind neu gemischt. Der Teppich bleibt, wo er ist. Teppich bleibt in der Kirche im Dorf, alles ist da, wo es ist, aber halt mit neuen Karten. Ja, das stimmt, aber... Hat er auch Karten gespielt im Monat? Nein, nein, nein. Nur Pokémon. Kann man mit Ditto gewinnen? Ach, hör auf, ey. Das ist das fucking schlimmste Thema aller Zeiten. Ich wollte mit Ditto das Spiel durchspielen, das ist die Hölle. Das ist die absolute Hölle, weiss, scheißegal. Normalerweise, wenn du mit einem Pokémon das Spiel durchspielst, ist dein Vorteil, dass du halt 20 Level über allen anderen Pokémon bist. Und auch wenn du ein Crab-Pokémon hittest, one-hitest du halt relativ schnell alles durch. So. Das dachte ich nämlich, Crab-Pokémon, es gibt ja ein Crab-Pokémon. Krabby, ja, Krabby. Das ist wirklich Krabby heißt. Und Karasek, Parasek. Helmut Parasek, ja.
Und das Problem an Ditto ist aber,
der kann sich ja immer nur in das gegnerische Pokémon verwandeln,
übernimmt aber dann auch die Stats. Die Kack-Stats.
Das heißt, du bist immer genauso stark wie das gegnerische Pokémon.
Und wenn du gegen Trainer spielst mit vier anderen Pokémon, vergiss es.
Also sind Ditto ein scheiß Pokémon einfach.
War eine absolute Katastrophe.
Ja. Es war wirklich schrecklich, es war wirklich furchtbar. Aber was hast du denn gewonnen am Ende des Tages? Stefan, es war furchtbar. Ja. Es war grauenvoll, es war der schlimmste Urlaub meines Lebens. Hast du dich erholen können? Stefan, es war furchtbar. Ich habe keine Postkarte bekommen, warum habe ich keine Postkarte bekommen? Weil es schrecklich war. Es war ein Albtraum, es war die Hölle. Richtig schlimm. Wegen Ditto. Fucking Ditto, aber was für ein fucking guter Name. Ja. Wie fucking gut sind die Pokémon-Namen? Die Deutschen auch, ne? Die Deutschen, weil die mussten ja ganz richtig viele Pokémon benennen. Und ich weiß nicht, wer das da macht in so einer Videospielfirma, weil das ist ja eigentlich eine Autoren- oder Übersetzeraufgabe, ob die da unbedingt immer Leute dafür haben. Ganz im Ernst, irgendwo, ich weiß das ja als jemand, der jetzt so ein paar Autoren-Steps schon durchgemacht hat in meinem Leben. So, jetzt weiß ich, diese Menschen sind mir nie begegnet. Heißt, selbst wenn ich in diese Richtung wollte, könnte ich es nicht. Heißt, irgendwo entstehen aus dem absoluten Vakuum Autorenjobs. Und zwar richtig gute Autorenjobs. Beispiel, wer übersetzt denn Filme? Blockbuster, so Disney-Filme oder so Flugzeuger-Riebig. Da hatten wir es ja auch schon mit. Wer übersetzt diese Filme? Somebody. Irgendwelche DialogautorInnen. Ja, Übersetzer. Ich glaube, da gibt es schon Übersetzer, die das machen. Wir haben übrigens noch ein paar Beispiele bekommen für sehr, sehr gute Übersetzungen. Es gibt zum Beispiel eine legendäre Szene in SpongeBob, wo er der fliegende Holländer Mr. Krabs weckt und er fragt, bist du Mr. Krabs? Und im Original sagt er nur No, my name is Jerry McJefferson oder irgendeinen Nonsensnamen. Im Deutschen hat Mr. Krabs aber dieselbe Synchronstimme wie Benjamin Blümchen und sagt in dem Moment, nein, nein, nein, ich bin Benjamin Blümchen. Und das ist fantastisch, weil irgendjemand muss die Idee ja gehabt haben, den Gag reinzuschreiben, weil das der selbe Synchronstimme ist. Wer hat diesen Gag gemacht? Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es vielleicht bei Sachen wie Pokémon ganz gut, weil aus einer Not heraus, ein Autor hätte das Schlangen-Pokémon halt Schlängli genannt oder irgendwie sowas, wohingegen Programmierer denkt sich, fuck, wie heisst das Ding, ja, Schlange rückwärts, Rettan, Natter rückwärts, Rettan, Kobra rückwärts, Arbok, sowas. Schlange rückwärts. Du wärst, ich muss mir auch das aufstellen. Wenn, okay, wenn Florentin
Pokémon übersetzt hätte,
würde Rettan
heissen Das müssen wir auch jetzt aufschreiben. Wenn Florentin Pokémon übersetzt hätte, würde Rettan heißen Egnalx. Egnalx, das klingt gar nicht mal so bescheuert. Im Englischen heißt er Ekans Snake rückwärts. Aber im Deutschen kannst du Schlagen nicht rückwärts machen, deswegen Natter. Aber das sind richtig gute Namen und jedes Jahr spiele ich Pokémon durch und jedes Mal finde ich neue Namen. Alpollo zum Beispiel, das Geist-Pokémon, wegen Albtraum, Alpollo, weil der heißt ja Apollon eigentlich, wenn es an dem Gott orientieren ist, aber da wird Alpollo, wegen Albtraum. Immer solche Sachen findet man. Alpollo und dann ist auch Gengar die Fortsetzung. Ja, Gengar, Nebulak, Alpollon, Alpollo und Gengar. Gengar. Alles daran ist auch noch hastisch. Gengar. Aber Ditto ist fantastisch. Weil da kannst du wirklich richtig dummen Namen machen. Wechseliese, irgendwie Schleimi oder irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich passe mir der an, Copy-Paste-Lon oder sowas. Ich passe mir dich an. Ich hasse dich. Ich hasse es. Ich hasse dich. Das macht dir alles kein Problem. Wohingegen Ditto ist perfekt. Ditto habe ich auch gerade gesagt. Ditto. Ditto. Ditto. Wie heisst es auf Englisch? Ditto. Ditto. Ditto? Super. Richtig gut. Seien die auch Ditto? Ditto. Nee. Das kennen die nicht, ne? Ditto. Ditto. Ditto. Ich glaube, ja. Ditto. Ditto glaube ich nicht, dass sie sagen. Aber ja, richtig toll, aber es war grauenvoll. Ich habe mich kaum erholen können, deswegen bin ich angespannt. Weiterhin rase ich auf dem Highway weiter. Ja, nimm mal die Sauna und schmiede ich mit Kaffee-Peelings ein und höre dabei den fucking Arrival-Soundjack und denke, dieses Erdenleben ist nichts mehr für mich.
Ich will das jeden Tag. Ich steige auf
zu einer höheren Evolutionsstufe
und schmiere mich mit Evolutionsschleim
ein. Ich habe Zeit anders
wahrgenommen in dem Zeitpunkt.
Als ich mit Kaffee zur Arrival-Musik
eingeschmiert habe, habe ich gedacht,
ich kannte Amy Adams schon,
ich werde sie kennen, ich werde Amy Adams gekannt haben.
Ich sag dir, im gleichen Moment, du kannst sie und du wirst sie kennen.
Zeitreise wird auch an Grammatik scheitern.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich glaube, erst muss Plus von Perfekt eingeführt werden und dann ist eine Kultur in der Lage, Zeitreisefilme zu machen,
weswegen Tintenfische noch keine Zeitreisefilme geschrieben haben. Aber ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis sie das getan haben werden. Und meldet euch und beim nächsten Filmpitch hast du einen Tintenfisch da, der dir einen interessanten Film pitcht. Es gab wirklich einen Tintenfisch-Film, Tintenfisch-Film, wie ich gesagt habe. Aber auch hier habe ich erst mal meine brenzige Frage gestellt, bevor Co-Autorin Jana Nanzig gesagt hat, erst mal vielen Dank für den tollen Film. Jedes Mal natürlich, das kann nicht da im Ernst. Erst mal vielen Dank, dass ihr da seid, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt, dass ihr extra hergefahren habt. Mir auf so einen Blick zu werfen. Also erst einmal, vielen, vielen Dank überhaupt, dass ihr da seid, okay? So ging mich alles nichts und die denken sich auch, ja, die nehmen das Problem gar nicht an, weil die denken es nur gegen den Typen, der gerade nicht gesagt hat, wie toll das ist, dass die da sind. Ja, macht sowas nicht, macht sowas nicht, wir fassen nochmal zusammen, der Erste, der spricht, setzt den sozialen Level fest, der darf nicht mehr überboten werden, grüssen nur auf gleicher Ebene Erstgrüsse haben soziale Vorteile. Einfach als Zweitgrüsse direkt zurückgrüssen. Und ihr könnt Macht missbrauchen, aber in einem gewissen Maße. Nur in einem gewissen Maße. Und falls ihr Tintenfische seid und euch langweilt, ist nicht unsere fucking Schuld. Macht uns nicht dafür schuldig, macht uns kein schlechtes Gewissen. Aber nehmt euch von mir mit meiner grossen Harpune in acht, weil ich habe ein Auge auf euch.
Versucht euch evolutionär ein bisschen zurückzuhalten, ein bisschen bescheiden zu bleiben.
Kriegt ihr hin, wir sagen tschau, bis nächste Woche.
Wir heben nämlich jetzt auch ab.